Avengers in this game one of you will  draw the rest of you will guess  welcome to The Avengers in  that's games with an S get it who wants  to draw first mark does my rough well  come on up here I'm coming here I come  oh let me look here on your mark get set  go  [Music]  hot dog bow and arrows hawkeye's arrows  Evan's Evan's got that right atlas when  it was ready Hawkeye's quiver of arrows  hey you can stop drawing it now we  guessed it there we go man chest bacon  what is that bacon our cool  oh that layer wait who said that who  said it first  Ryder Ryder said it first alright here  we go Freddy did he's running a new 500  points whoever gets a garlic garlic yeah  all right who's next are scarlet you got  this this Falcons wings we hold on tall  expands Hulkbuster hulking out poke  smash Hulk smash baby I am you Tony  alright alright come on ready three two  one yeah rhymes  the winner of this game is he stayed  clear of it chris hemsworth  [Music]  you